ladies and gentlemen here they are the
heart
dra the fun
boy the sensitive
one the
leader and the
baby give me up
foro she
go flow let's do this no more
talking did anybody
notice the energy just shifted When we
dropped it let to drop
it I don't fle but I might about the T
white cuz the N is Young and the music's
on and we got love on S the the limit
now the Stars living it's the in it
andf
the
great it's working yes come on
[Music]
guys what's he doing this isn't
[Applause]
myo
ow got
[Music]
you ladies and Gentlemen please stand by
uh we're
experiencing some stuff hey at least we
didn't
fall we
fell follow that laury vehicle on it
puppy
what's up
outrageous you didn't think we were just
going to give you a boring Old Stage
show did you that's what we explicitly
bought tickets for we're taking this
show on the
[Applause]
road man I'm trying to get through but
they got no respect for the
[Music]
blinker
sweet dreams are made of this who am I
to I travel the world in Seven
Seas
everybody looking for
something oh this is too much I only
have my permit tiny give me the thing
what thing you know the thing thing M
come on Tiny don't do me like that yeah
I knew what you was talking
[Music]
about oh oh that's good brch there they
are hold her steady tiny want to abuse
you some of them want to be
franch hang tight Floyd we'll get you
guys out of here Ming
on uping
on uh guys what does End of the Road
[Music]
mean
I'm going to live
forever I'm going to learn how to
fly I feel it com
together people will see me and cry oh
no what do we do let's
hustle hey it's hustleman can you please
drop us off at that boat down there
absolutely not
literally
Bridget Crystle perfect timing we would
have been here sooner but we had to make
a pickup
first Eva you showed up yeah I know
right I'm kind of freaking out a little
bit you've got a Really Brave sister
actually I've got two Really Brave
sisters poppy I'm really sorry about
before it's okay our story is
complicated who cares if it's it's not
perfect as long as we're
together I should have come with you I
was just did you just braid my hair yeah
I learned from the best oh my gosh it is
so fantastic amazing oh no hold on your
cupcakes hang on tght Chrissy what are
you
doing
go get awesome
sisters to
[Applause]
to viva viva baby are you guys all right
yes but we're not done yet let's
bro I'm going
forever learn how
[Applause]
to
to snap it take you to a better
place I'm going to make you kiss the sky
T night yeah if you let me show the way
he I'm so excited to see you
excited a better Yoo and baby you can
love me on the way but you up to out to
space your face I'm so excited to see
you
excited I like to see you lose
control no better do it better I know a
place that you go
[Music]
with just let me take it to a better
place there a face I'm going to make you
kiss the sky tonight and if you let me
show the
way I'm so excited to see you excited
I'm take you to a
better and baby you can love me all the
way
to I'm so excited to see you
I like to see you lose
controlin nobody better we do it better
I know a play say that you'll go
[Music]
[Applause]
with poppy I have a small
proposal will you join the band of
course I will I thought you would never
ask you know me too well now get up here
and sing with
USA get up here we're in the
F this is my dream life the Only Rule is
get on your feet I don't want to see
nobody heating up their
seat and if you believe it if you B it
no matter where you're from the apple
don't fall far from it now people want
to know when the see is dancing want to
know how we got those mules people want
to bottle it up up up up up but no can
do people want to know how to find that
feeling want to know how we got that
Groove they're thirsty for the juice but
I'mma tell you the truth
o runs in my
[Music]
family
ooh it runs in the
family it's all about you and me